so colin it's lovely to see you here at
londonville on comic con have you been
having time today having a very good
time it's been a lot it's a sunday which
is usually a quiet day and this has been
packed and it's been lovely to meet so
many people who love what we do now
people would slap me if i went without
asking you something about the five-ish
doctor's reboot and the
sequel that paul morgan talked about
recently what did you think when you
read about that or what did you think
when you heard there was going to be a
sequel
um paul mcgann clearly knows more than i
do um
all i know is when i last spoke to peter
uh the reaction to fiveish doctors has
been
so positive
uh
that we discussed whether it was a good
idea to do another one
and we agreed that we didn't want to do
one
that was a pale imitation of the first
one that would be
kind of anticlimactic so until we come
up with a really good idea
and there's a couple of possibilities
floating around
um
and you know there's nothing set in
stone but i'm sure
that if we could think of something that
would
add to rather than diminish what we've
already done
then we'd all be happy to do it
certainly
now if you do anything in that sequel
what would you like to do
well clearly that would
spoil the
novelty of the sequel so i'm not going
to tell you
i assumed that it would be peter
davidson writing and directing again
yeah
you're talking as if it's a definite
thing
um
all that's happened is we've
been inundated with people wanting more
and we've been going well unless we can
do it
as well or better there's no point
uh
so
just wait and see i have no idea i mean
if you could because we had such a
fantastic mix of people in the in the
reboot didn't we um so many great people
the doctors we had barrowman we had
moffat and russell sue davies we had
jackson in there and doing mckellen and
more and more and more olivia coleman
and
start um if you could have anybody in a
future one if we come back for another
one who would you like to see in it you
see i if there was a reboot of the
reboot
i i don't think going down that path
would be a good idea
um
if there is to be a reboot i would favor
having it the three of us doing
something um
the one that we did at the anniversary
was a special one related to the 50th
anniversary
um
clearly
doing one about the 51st anniversary
isn't going to be interesting so it's
got to be about something else
so
arbitrarily boating on people at this
point
isn't really a
good idea we wanted to ask you also
about the audio dr who's that you do as
well what can we look forward to coming
up with those
um i am constantly doing big finish
audios and loving doing them
i got one shuttle for august i'm doing
uh
i think of all the stuff that i've done
the last few years it's the body of work
that i'm proudest of
because the standard remains constantly
very very high the standard of writing
is always
higher and higher
so
each new script comes in and i'm excited
when they come colin have you got a
message for fans out there who love your
work
um i'd just like to thank everybody who
is still interested in something i did
30 years ago me and my
stalwart companions megan over there and
all the others
we've had a ball doing the work and now
we're delighted to know that
you enjoy watching it as much as we
enjoyed doing it long may it continue